this episode is sponsored by endl an app
that creates personalized soundscapes to
help you focus relax and sleep the first
hundred people to click the link in the
description will get a free one week
trial
[Music]
when you look out at a pond you are
rarely ever staring at just a body of
water some sort of liquid mass separate
from the trees and vegetation around it
the pond itself is usually full of life
sometimes as large as a fish sometimes
as small as a bacterium
but sometimes those tinier organisms
come together to form large colonies
that coat the sediment in and around the
pond like these veggiatoa which might
look like bits of string unfurling
underneath the microscope but are
actually hundreds of individual bacteria
that have attached to each other to
create a filament
veggiatoa are silver bacteria and you
can see the sulfur they've all stored
shining as the filament glides past
glittering like a diamond studded
bracelet
and just as the bacteria gather to form
a filament the filaments gather to form
a mat weaving together tens of thousands
of veggiatoa into a white carpet that
lines surfaces found in marine and
freshwater habitats alike
and that is great news for james our
master of microscopes because one of his
sampling ponds happens to have some of
these veggiatoa carpets making it very
easy for him to just collect a bit from
the mat to check out under the
microscope or at least
it used to be easy
recently for some reason the pond hasn't
yielded quite as much veggietoa as it
used to in fact it's barely produced any
we don't know quite what happened but
james suspects a new resident of the
pond a family of beavers that could have
potentially changed some of the chemical
composition
making it less habitable for the
vegiatoa
but in its place
another bacteria has come to take over
the thick biofilms of the pond
filamentous cyanobacteria and while
there's plenty to distinguish one from
the other there's one very important
trait that unites them and makes them
similarly mysterious
it is in the way
they move
maybe you've picked up on it already the
long lengths of vegiatoa and
cyanobacteria gliding across the slide
there are only a few groups of bacteria
that do this kind of gliding but they're
found across a plethora of environments
including ponds soil and surprise in our
own mouths those fast-moving bacteria
are largely moving with the aid of
flagella a helical structure powered by
atp that propels the bacteria in
different directions
but gliding does not involve those
flagella
gliding involves something much more
slick than flagella complex
polysaccharides which scientists call by
a much cooler name
slime
a thread gliding across slime sounds
more like an arts and crafts project
gone wrong than a complex form of motion
that shapes entire ecosystems but of
course that is exactly what gliding
turns out to be
to appreciate the importance of this
movement let's continue with
cyanobacteria which have been
photosynthesizing and oxygenating our
world for billions of years
they are small but the impact they are
able to have on the world around them is
huge
and all this without the aid of flagella
to move them around of course it would
be a massive challenge for cyanobacteria
to survive if they couldn't move
anywhere
they are photosynthetic organisms after
all so even if they're not hunting down
prey they are on the hunt for sunlight
fortunately they already have the tools
in place to sense sunlight the pigments
they use to perform photosynthesis can
also when they detect light set off the
reactions that drive the cyanobacteria
in the right direction
but not all light is the same
some species of cyanobacteria for
example will glide away from blue light
while others ignore color and instead
gauge their response based on the
intensity of light these responses will
vary with the species as will the way
they glide
some can bend others can rotate along
the axis of their filament but the end
result is the same a slow but directed
movement in search of light that will
one day be food
but these filamentous cyanobacteria have
hit on more than just a steady graceful
path towards the light they are
collective organisms
gathering into filaments and mats they
can even aggregate into toxic blooms
that can span hundreds of square miles
suffocating or poisoning the unfortunate
organisms that come in contact with them
and one of the challenges of forming
these kinds of collections is that it
requires diverting resources towards
making the extracellular structures that
keep the cells together and that can
come at the expense of dividing and
making more cyanobacteria so if there
are disadvantages there must be an
advantage and there's a big one
by working together these colonies can
allow the individuals to better pursue a
collective goal and gliding happens to
just be one of those collective goals in
the case of the model cyanobacteria
species cynicasistus researchers have
found that while individuals of the
species can navigate in response to
light they are better able to orient
themselves to light when they are
attached to each other it's like they go
from stumbling individuals to a
well-choreographed dance line and the
mathematical models suggest that even if
a fraction of this colony can't respond
to light the overall movement around
them will stay the same taking everyone
towards light and towards photosynthesis
and continued life
so this seemingly simple movement brings
complexity to these seemingly simple
organisms and scientists have been
trying to decipher the mechanisms that
drive gliding for
many decades now we mentioned earlier
that where there's gliding there is also
slime but we don't know
what that slime is actually doing there
have been theories of course in one
potential mechanism the gliding
cyanobacteria
oozes slime to power it along the
surface in another waves travel down the
length of the filament to push it along
the surface but even as scientists have
identified more of the components
driving the movement of filament to
cyanobacteria the process or even
whether there is just one process
remains unclear
it seems like it should be so much more
obvious doesn't it
that there should be an easy answer we
know so much about flagella and our own
system of locomotion with legs well that
seems pretty obvious but then maybe
that's what makes this so beautiful and
infuriatingly difficult to explain
despite how long we have been working to
explain it
for now at least it is a movement
without an obvious metaphor
one day
we'll think of something
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we glide through the unseen
world
that surrounds us
thank you also to endl for sponsoring
this episode endl is an app that creates
personalized soundscapes to help you
focus relax and
sleep it uses ai technology the
pentatonic scale and pure intonation to
create simple pleasant sounds that can
help to calm your mind
sound has a direct impact on your
physical and mental well-being and by
adapting in real time to things like
your location your weather your heart
rate endle can help you out whether you
just want to sit back and relax or if
you're having trouble getting a good
deep sleep and if you're looking for
something to study to you could check
out their new deeper focus collaboration
with musician plastic man if you're
interested in trying out endle you
should try to be one of the first 100
people to click on the link in the
description because if you do you will
get a one week free trial
there are now arriving on your screen a
bunch of names these are people all
across the world who support us on
patreon we have a little weird show here
and it's not designed to go super duper
viral and get a huge huge audience so
that it can
buy lots of expensive microscope
equipment so instead we have patrons on
patreon they are lovely they are the
reason we can make this show thank you
to all of you so much if you want to
learn how to become a patron you can go
to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button
somewhere nearby
[Music]